hello everyone this is emir from
audioscience review
this is another uh episode on uh inside
your
high resolution music uh this time uh
another sampler um and format comparison
uh
set of files from another label that i
really like
it's called sound liaison as you see
here
they have really really well recorded
music and
as with the 2l label they're kind enough
to provide a
format comparison page and free content
that you can download
so if you scroll down here you'll see
the list of files that they provide
a little bit of nuisance in that you
have to add them to the cart
and go through the checkout process but
it won't ask you for any credit card
information so
feel free to go through the process and
uh
download these tracks as you can see the
wide-ranging
set of tracks from dxd at the highest
resolution
and then down sample pcm versions
excuse me and following on with some dst
files i've gone ahead and and downloaded
those files
um bringing them over here
you can see them here in the past i
mentioned how
my audio analysis uh workstation
software
audition can't open and manipulate
dxd files or dsd files
and to remedy that i'm using a new
program
actually the program's been out for a
while but i haven't shown it to you
before
it's called music scope uh i think the
name of the company is
xivera or something like that just
google
uh music scope and you'll find it it's
about
28 euros i think to purchase it the test
version stops at 30 seconds
which makes it difficult to use for this
kind of analysis so if you want to use
it you probably need to
purchase the whole uh software for the
28 euros
i'm not a big fan of the program it
looks pretty it shows a lot of stuff
but for the type of analysis i want to
do on it this is restrictive
um simple things like there's no slider
bar to go to different parts of the
music
at least not one that i've discovered
and
uh things like analysis when they are
all static and that you can't rescale
them easily
so not a big fan but uh it does the job
in here so
let's go ahead and uh bring in the high
resolution uh the highest resolution
sample that they uh provide at sound
liaison
it's loaded into here if we look in here
says it's 24 bits
pcm at 350 to 0.8 kilohertz sampling
rate
uh it nicely shows these uh the
bandwidth in the fourier transform as uh
nice multiples of of uh
the audio rates so uh 352.8 kilohertz
has 166.4 killers
worth of bandwidth and you can see where
cds 44.1 is way to heck out here
so with that said let's go ahead and and
uh play this
um so far one nice thing we see is just
exceptionally wide bandwidth uh as far
as the spectrum
music uh if you look this looks like
noise but it actually oscillates up and
down
with the peaks doesn't do it all the
time but uh
it doesn't look like pure noise to me
now the levels are very low at 100
uh minus 100 dbfs
but uh it's still we see content
you can see even out here all the way up
to 176 kilos
we say content but a remarkable thing
just happened let me pause this
notice what happened we had a very nice
beautiful
exponential decay but that all of a
sudden
all this nastiness popped in we got this
peak in here this one
this all this nonsense really true
garbage
popped in i'm going to go ahead and and
play this again so we notice it but
again
look in here this is what i was saying
example of very pure nice clean music
everything's correlated there are no
extraneous peaks
in here we can see in our spectrogram
the heat map nicely fades into nothing
here
there's a line in here but otherwise
it looks very clean notice what's going
to happen in a in a couple of seconds
noise floor just went up ah
did you realize what happened the vocals
came in
as soon as the vocal track was brought
in
everything fell apart clearly all this
garbage that we see
is in that vocal track it was recorded
separately
probably than the rest of the band and
whatever microphone recording technique
adc was used brought in
tons of garbage it took a super pristine
recording
and immediately trashed it down
objectively speaking
and with all this garbage and the
garbage now goes
way down low you can see that even
down here below 44.1 kilohertz oh
sorry i made a mistake before this is
the bandwidth of 44.1 clear cds way out
here so
for cds probably okay but for high
resolution
content look at all the trash that we
now have
none of this is correlated with our
beautiful music that starts here
and should exponentially drop off we
have all kinds of anomalies if i
continue playing this
you can see the anomaly show up in the
heat map
all this garbage down here so
we now know what the problem is
unfortunately the folks that created the
music
didn't notice this per my comments in
previous videos
you know we can't hear all this despite
all the fanfare for uh
you know using and buying high
resolution music we don't hear it the
producer doesn't hear him
so the garbage gets out but you know
they want to charge a lot of money for
this content it's their responsibility
to clean it up
and not let stuff like this happen you
can see how easy it is to uh
find this kind of problem just
doing a bit of measurements and bam you
know just
you gotta be blind to not be able to see
this so
let's go down to lower case
pcm files and unfortunately the same
issue arises because all that noise that
i was showing you was in this region
this starts off clean uh as before we've
now
chopped off half of our spectrum uh
we're at 88.2 kilohertz now you can see
how high resolution
all of this is remarkably wide bandwidth
recording
88 kilohertz of true music peaks
this is just unbelievably nice and high
resolution
if that vocal track hadn't screwed it up
and here comes the vocal track again
all of this appeared notice that it's
before she even sings
it's just when they bring him fading it
up
we start to hear all the see all this in
in the
uh in the noise of the background
uh that it brings so
i won't bore you but you know we can go
the way down to 44.1 kilohertz and
obviously that's going to look fine
we just have a more detailed view now
into the
spectrum of the music but nothing
exciting so i'll go ahead and stop this
now let's look at our dsd and let's look
at the
highest rate one that we have which is
uh
uh 250 xc256 um
quad sampled uh dsd
and let's play that and now we see a
another disaster in the making
so out here we have about
26 kilos worth of uh useful music so a
sort of sampling rate would be 50 kilos
or so
and then we see some nothingness here
then we see
garbage in here uh you know some other
laws as to how they managed to do this
um you know i can see the noise shaping
which is as i've explained before
one bit noise shaping requires that we
push up uh let me pause this that we
take the noise that's generated by
having too few bits
and pushing it up to ultrasonic so
that's understandable
but how did they manage to truncate all
this stuff
above 25 killers you know
it's this just not correct
something's really a miss in here the
recording was the xd
uh what the format converter is doing is
uh
york is a good in mind look at how the
music spectrum here in the
heat map nicely shows in spectral gram
here where we
stop right around here uh
and then we go to nothing and then we
have this pure noise it's
very very clean so we know it's noise
so we're not getting high resolution
anybody's praising this
over the pcm you know they need to go
back and re-listen to the pcm because
the pcm had
gorgeous bandwidth all the way out here
no noise shaping
garbage like this this is just
really really puzzling uh let's go to a
lower bit
data rate the original dst 64 and see
what that does
oh boy so we now
see the same problem here uh
where again our musical information ends
abruptly at uh
26 kilohertz and all this garbage shows
up
actually what i think they may have done
is that they've taken a
low sampling rate uh pcm version
and then up sampled it to dsd
causing this noise shaping to appear
over here
but the original music content was
already truncated you can see it in the
history here
uh it drops off like an anti-aliasing
filter would
if we had resampled the original dxd so
something's
sharply bringing the uh frequency
response down and
you know we're going back yeah it's
about this is about 48 kilo
sampling worth of data you're getting
plus a heap of noise
uh again folks that think the dsd sounds
better
they really need to go back to the
drawing board
i don't care what they think their ears
are telling them
if their ears aren't you know able to
figure out that
you know most of the bandwidth is cut
and replaced with just garbage
uh i don't know what to tell them i mean
uh maybe there's some system out there
that
all of a sudden magically sounds better
when you pump bunch of noise into it
but this is just not acceptable
um goes back to my theory of get the
original
let me do the conversion if that's all
they've done is converted the sd64
themselves
or any of these other dsds let me do the
conversion i could do a better job
myself
if the original was dxd 352 which i
suspect
it was then let me uh
do the chopping in this case i would
have listened to it
found where the vocal track started to
add all that garbage
i would then choose a lower sampling
rate to truncate all that
and uh call it done
so another uh mystery here
of how the production is occurring for
uh
high resolution reminds me of of uh
fear that the tv broadcasters had when
we went from
high definition from standard definition
to high definition
they said they had to remake all their
sets because they all
would look like cheap cardboard and
cheap furniture
that in the softer low resolution
standard definition video was not
visible but once you made it high
definition
all the warts came out and they had to
really go back and make high quality
stuff
by the same token so much of music
production today goes into
low resolution formats that all these
sins are
left on the table and weren't visible
now that we want to deliver them
you know we realize you know or people
should realize how bad it is
so anyway i hope you found this
informative this is amir from
audiosciencereview.com
talk to you later in a future video bye